REPORT TONIGHT.
I WANT TO GET NOW LIVE TO KYIV.
THEY WERE MARRIED ON THE FIRST
DAY OF THE RUSSIAN INVASION.
THEY HAVE SINCE TAKEN UP ARMS TO
DEFEND THEIR COUNTRY, AND YURINA
ALSO SERVES ON THE KYIV CITY
COUNCIL.
WE'RE SO HAPPY TO SEE YOU GUYS
HERE AND SAFE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS DOING?
>> THANK YOU.
WE ARE OKAY RIGHT NOW.
MY HUSBAND HAD TO STAY ON THE
POST FOR THREE HOURS, SO HE GOT
CALLED AND JUST CAME BACK A FEW
MINUTES AGO.
THOUGH I WAS TRYING TO TAKE SOME
SLEEP JUST BECAUSE IT'S THE ONLY
TIME, YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T SLEEP
HERE WHEN YOU WANT TO.
YOU SLEEP HERE WHEN YOU HAVE AN
ABILITY TO BECAUSE THERE IS A
LOT OF WORK TO DO.
THE SITUATION IN KYIV IS MOSTLY
OKAY RIGHT NOW, BUT STILL WE
HEAR SOME EXPLOSIONS, AND
YESTERDAY THERE WAS ONE
EXPLOSION IN A DISTRICT IN KYIV
VERY, VERY CLOSE TO MY
GRANDMOTHER'S HOUSE, LIKE IN HER
HOUSE THE WINDOWS WERE EVEN
BROKEN BECAUSE OF THE
EXPLOSIONS, BECAUSE OF THE
STRENGTH OF IT.
AND IT WAS REALLY SAD BECAUSE I
HAVE SPENT MY YOUTH, MY
CHILDHOOD IN THERE IN THAT YARD,
AND RIGHT NOW IT IS DESTROYED.
THE EXPLOSION WAS ONE OF THE
FLATS AND IT WAS ABSOLUTELY ON
FIRE AND COMPLETELY DESTROYED
LIKE EVERYTHING IN IT.
IT IS REALLY SAD, AND IT'S
REALLY STRANGE TO SEE HOW OUR
CITY CHANGES, LIKE A LOT OF --
ALL AROUND KYIV, A LOT OF
BLOCKS, A LOT OF THE THINGS
STANDING LIKE THE ROADS BLOCKING
THE WAY FOR THE TANKS OR IF THEY
WILL TRY TO GET TO THE CENTER OF
KYIV TO THE GOVERNMENTAL
STREETS.
IT IS REALLY STRANGE ALSO, BUT
IT'S REALLY KIND OF WEIRD WHEN
IT'S LIKE NIGHT, AND THERE IS NO
CARS.
THERE IS NO PEOPLE.
IT'S LIKE A COMPLETE SILENCE.
YOU CAN HEAR YOUR OWN HEARTBEAT.
BECAUSE IN ALL THE FLATS IT IS
ALSO LIKE ABSOLUTELY NO SOUNDS,
LIKE EVERYTHING IS ASLEEP OR HAS
MOVED AWAY, AND IT IS REALLY
LIKE STRONG.
WHAT ABOUT KYIV CITY COUNCIL,
YES, WE HAD A PLANNED RECESSION
THE DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY BECAUSE
WE NEEDED TO MAKE SOME DECISIONS
TO HELP TO PROTECT THE CITY, AND
WE HAVE MOVED ONE AND THREE --
1.3 BILLION FROM CITY BUDGET TO
THE PROTECTING THE CITY LIKE TO
MAKING THOSE -- TO BUYING SOME
FOR THE DEFENSE AND SO ON.
AND ALSO WE MADE LIKE MAIL TO
OUR CITY'S BROTHERS AND ALSO ONE
MAIL FOR OUR CITY BROTHER MINSK
BECAUSE MINSK A CITY BROTHER OF
KYIV ASKING THEM NOT TO JOIN THE
FIGHT AGAINST UKRAINIANS AND
TELLING THEM THAT IF THEY WILL,
WE WON'T BE BROTHERS ANYMORE.
>> YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUR
BROTHER CITY IN RUSSIA NOT TO
JOIN THE FIGHT AGAINST -- IN
BELARUS NOT TO JOIN THE FIGHT,
AND THEN YOUR CITY COUNCIL YOU
SAID IS THE SET UP DEFENSE FUNDS
TO TRY TO HELP YOU.
LISTEN, IT'S AMAZING TO HEAR,
YOU KNOW, TO SEE YOU GUYS THERE,
BUT ALSO TO HEAR YOU SPEAK WITH
SUCH CLARITY ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
DOING, AND YOU HAVE A LIST THERE
BECAUSE YOU WANT TO GET THAT
OUT, AND I THINK THAT IS VERY
COMMENDABLE.
I HAVE TO ASK -- I'M NOT ASKING
YOU WHERE YOU ARE, BUT I JUST
WANT TO KNOW IF THE BOMBS HAVE
COME TO NEAR WHERE YOU GUYS ARE.
>> RIGHT NOW WE ARE AT THE
CHURCHILL DEFENSE FORCE BASE --
>> DON'T TELL ME WHERE YOU ARE,
I DON'T WANT TO KNOW.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW IF THE BOMBS
ARE NEAR --
>> I WON'T TELL YOU THE ADDRESS.
THERE IS A LOT OF BASES OF
CHURCHILL DEFENSE IN KYIV, AND
RIGHT NOW WE ARE IN THE CENTER
OF KYIV REALLY CLOSE TO THE
GOVERNMENTAL STREETS, AND IT IS
ALMOST SILENT IN HERE, BUT WHEN
YOU GO OUT LIKE THE STREETS, YOU
CAN HEAR SOME EXPLOSIONS, BUT
IT'S FAR AWAY.
-- THAT IS NOT KIND OF --
>> WHAT DID YOU SAY?
>> YES, I CAN HEARD SOME
EXPLOSIONS TODAY.
IT'S NOT -- SILENCE UP TO MAYBE
2:00 A.M., AFTER THAT IT WAS
COMPLETELY SILENT.
>> YOU KNOW THE LAST TIME I
SPOKE, YOU WERE OUT ON A MISSION
WITH THE DEFENSE FORCE.
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THOSE
MISSIONS HAVE BEEN LIKE?
>> YES, I WAS JUST -- IT WAS THE
SECOND MISSION.
I WAS -- IT WAS SECOND MISSION,
RIGHT?
>> SECOND, YES.
>> SECOND MISSION.
I WAS ON THE NEXT POSITION ON
THE KYIV BORDERS JUST TO -- I
WAS TEACHING OUR CIVILIANS HOW
TO DO A MOLOTOV COCKTAILS, JUST
OUT OF MY HANDS WITH THAT WORK.
AND ACTUALLY, WE DO SOME
POSITIONS.
THAT COULD TRY TO BREAK THROUGH
OUR -- JUST FIGHTING WITH
SOME -- SABOTAGE GROUPS.
>> SO WERE YOU IN DIRECT CONTACT
WITH RUSSIAN SOLDIERS?
>> YES.
WE HAVE SOME CONTACT.
>> YOU DID?
>> YES, I DID.
>> TALK TO ME ABOUT IT.
>> WELL, IT WAS A SABOTAGE GROUP
IN THE FOREST NEAR OUR
POSITIONS.
WE JUST HAVE A SECRET POSITION
WHICH FROM -- WHICH WE JUST LOOK
IN THE FOREST, I'VE BEEN LOOKING
AT THE FOREST, YES, AND JUST
SOME SABOTAGE GROUPS ARE TRYING
TO FIND OUR ARTILLERY AND
POSITION.
WE HAVE FIRE ON OUR POSITION
JUST FROM OUR -- FROM OUR
ENEMIES, JUST SOMETHING LIKE --
>> IT WAS FLYING ABOUT THEIR
HEADS.
>> FLYING ABOUT OUR HEADS.
IT'S REALLY A NOISY PLACE.
>> WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS LIKE
OUT THERE?
I THINK ARINA SAID YOU WERE OUT
IN THE COLD?
YOU WERE COLD?
>> YES, A LITTLE BIT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT MY COLD, IT'S
JUST ABOUT MY HANDS AND MY
FEET --
>> AND NOSE.
>> AND NOSE, YES, OF COURSE, AND
NOSE, BUT --
>> WHAT ARE THE CONDITIONS LIKE
OUT THERE?
TALK TO US ABOUT WHAT IT'S LIKE
BEING OUT THERE?
BECAUSE YOU SAID YOU WERE WITH
THE SABOTAGE GROUP AND YOU WERE
LOOKING.
SOME OF THE CONVOY, THAT 40 MILE
LONG CONVOY HAVE MADE ITS WAY
WE'RE TOLD INTO THE TOWNS AND
INTO WOODS, WHAT HAVE YOU.
HAVE YOU BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND SOME OF
THE TANKS THAT HAVE BEEN -- OR
IS THIS JUST SORT OF HAND TO
HAND?
>> I THINK HAPPILY WE HAVEN'T
GOT SOME CONTACT.
THAT'S BECAUSE IT JUST REALLY,
REALLY MANY FIRE FROM OUR SIDE.
IT'S LIKE OUR MISSION WAS JUST
TO PROTECT OUR ARTILLERY AND
MACHINES AND JUST HOLD OUR
POSITIONS AND CATCH THE SABOTAGE
GROUPS THAT WANT TO -- WANT TO
CORRECT THE ENEMY FIRE JUST FROM
OUR POSITIONS, POSITION OF OUR
COMRADES, AND ACTUALLY DESTROY
OUR ARTILLERY AND MACHINES.
>> WHEN I FIRST SPOKE TO YOU, TO
BOTH OF YOU, YOU SAID THAT YOU
HAVE NO DOUBT THAT UKRAINE WILL
WIN THE WAR.
DO YOU STILL FEEL THAT WAY
TONIGHT?
>> OF COURSE I DO.
PEOPLE DON'T LOSE THEIR
STRENGTH.
ALSO IT GROWS WITH EVERY DAY.
WITH EVERY KILLED CHILD, WOMAN
WITH EVERY DESTROYED HOUSE,
HOSPITAL, MATERNITY, PEOPLE ARE
BECOMING MORE AND MORE ANGRY.
LIKE I USUALLY COME TO SMOKE
SOMEWHERE AND I HEAR OUR GUYS
STILL TALKING TO EACH OTHER, AND
THEY ARE LIKE, OH, USUALLY I'M A
PACIFIST.
I HATE BLOOD, I HATE VIOLENCE,
BUT RIGHT NOW I WANT TO KILL AND
I WANT TO KILL AS MUCH AS I CAN.
AND THAT REALLY IS WEIRD, LIKE
PEOPLE IN HERE ARE KIND.
PEOPLE IN HERE ARE THINKING
FIRST ABOUT THEIR FAMILIES,
ABOUT THEIR HOMES.
WE ARE REALLY KIND OF ARCHAIC
NATION.
THE MOST AVAILABLE THINGS FOR US
IS OUR FAMILIES, OUR HOMES, OUR
CHILDREN.
WE TREAT EACH OTHER AS BROTHERS
AND SISTERS.
THAT IS I THINK THE MAIN
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN US AND
RUSSIANS.
LIKE THEY ARE ONE FOR THEM, AND
THEY TRY TO LEAVE LIKE ALONE,
ALONE FOR HIMSELF.
BUT WE FEEL PAIN FOR EVERY
CHILD, LIKE WE'LL FEEL PAIN FOR
A CHILD KILLED IN MARIUPOL, AS
FOR OUR BROTHER'S OR SISTER'S
CHILD BECAUSE WE FEEL LIKE EACH
OTHER AS ONE NATION, AS ONE BIG
FAMILY, AND IT'S REALLY GOOD.
AND THAT REALLY HELPS US.
THAT HELPED